c'était le 22 avril au jeu mardi à 9
heures du mans tout une voiture bourrée
d'explosifs un mot 63 blessés auteur
présumé de l'attentât carlos accompagne
magdalena kopp comparis ya quelques
recruteurs de ban ki moon en
correctionnelle paris le 7 juin dernier
jean luc rivière dans le cadre de son
instruction sur cet attentat
il lance un mandat d'arrêt comprenant
terroristes un premier mandat d'arrêt
avait déjà été lancé sans succès le 9
janvier 1976 quelques mois après le
meurtre du tout lié à paris de deux
inspecteurs de la dst les deux hommes
étaient venus avec carlos carnot les
abeilles aux côtés de charles pasqua cet
après-midi le patron actuel de la
direction de la surveillance du
territoire n'avait pas oublié une
fidélité au souvenir de ceux qui sont
morts de celui qui a été baissé
une fidélité aux veuves aux orphelins et
et à gage de professionnalisme
c'est quelque chose de très important
pour la dst et surtout en cette année du
cinquantenaire ce service un
anniversaire pour la guerre estimé une
année à venir a priori difficile pour la
justice le 1er juin
12 carlos avait été condamné par
contumace à la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité
selon le droit français doit à présent
être rejugé par la cour d'assises de
paris uniquement composée de magistrats
une formation spéciale pour les affaires
de terrorisme
en attendant le procès la france
doit-elle craindre d'autres attentats
réponse de monsieur pasqua je ne le sais
pas c'est possible mais je ne le crois
pas de toute façon il est normal qu'un
pays qui a été victime d'un certain
nombre d'attentats terroristes et dont
un certain nombre de citoyens ont été
assassinés façon forte
le responsable de ces attentats soient
traduits devant la justice dès demain
carlo sera présenté au juge bruguière
le malade qui rentrent de vacances et
qui devrait le mettre en examen dans le
cadre de la campagne de leur du marbre
en attendant sûrement de ré ouvrir
d'autres informations contre les
terroristes pour tous les autres
attentats qui l'a vraisemblablement que
mon 30